[Music]
for decades Italian Engineers have been
working on designs for a massive project
one that could help solve one of
Southern Italy's biggest Problems by
connecting 5 million people in Sicily to
the mainland bringing jobs and growth to
the economically depressed Southern
regions the final goal a 12.7 billion
Mega project called the massina straight
Bridge which if completed will be the
world's longest suspension bridge nobody
has ever built such a big bridge so it
is an incredible challenge building a
bridge that's more than 2 miles long in
an area with gale force winds and
frequent earthquakes is neither easy nor
cheap here's how Italy plans to pull it
off to understand why this tra is so
dangerous here's a look at the tectonic
fault lines in the Mediterranean experts
say this line which runs right under the
proposed bridge is where the Eurasian
and African tectonic plates meet
notoriously active it caused a 7.5
magnitude quake in 1908 and 150 years
later which reached 6.1 magnitude the
fault line also created this narrow
Corridor when winds from the south
funnel into it they pick up speed as
they're squeezed into less space at
times reaching up to 170 mph winds like
this can be devastating for bridges in
1940 the Tacoma Nero suspension bridge
in Washington famously collapsed in high
winds at the time was the third longest
suspension bridge in the world so how
are Engineers planning to tackle these
challenges we visited Columbia's
engineering lab to learn more this is
raunda betti a suspension bridge expert
he consulted on the massina Bridge's
early designs in the 9s he says that a
suspension bridge gets its stability
from cables that attached the deck to
sets of towers supported with vertical
struts so when you have a car going over
this bridge the car is on the deck deck
then the deck transfer this load through
the suspender to the main cable the main
cable distributes the load to the towers
and to the anchorages the MSA bridge
will be held up by two gigantic Towers
each 60 ft taller than the Empire State
Building the deck will be 2.2 M long and
take about 10 minutes to Cross by car
making it over 50% longer than the
current record holder the
6,637 ft long kic bridge in Turkey
mesina is over 3 kilm free span so now
you are pushing the envelope not just of
few meters but you are pushing the
envelope of about almost a kilm while
that jumping length is a construction
challenge it's also a solution to one of
those big environmental
dangers experts say that extra kilometer
of deck will help protect the bridge
from seismic activity imagine this piece
of balsa wood is a bridge deck this
cross-section is this long okay if I
take this piece instead and I bend it
this one is much more flexible because
it is much more longer the idea is that
in an earthquake the deck will bend
slowly registering less seismic activity
like a large ship in small waves moving
upward one of the Bridge's newest
engineering developments is these
hourglass shaped struts they let the
legs Flex more than a traditional
cross-shaped strut when there's a quake
between the flexible deck and legs the
bridge could theoretically withstand a
7.5 magnitude earthquake the highest of
any structure in the world sizmic is
going to be important but seismic we
know how to design for seismic the major
major concern in my opin for these
Bridges is the wind on a bridge strong
winds can look like this you may the
excessive motion of this bridge way left
and right left and right that impairs
the traffic that people say I'm not
going to I'm not going there so to
prevent that Engineers created a new
kind of deck the Masina type deck this
cross-section shows three box gears the
two others were for vehicular traffic
the inner one was for train traffic and
then these box gears are connected by a
a very tide skin of crossbars all these
lanes and tracks will be capable of
supporting up to 6,000 cars per hour and
200 trains per day and see how the side
girs are tapered the crosswind will kind
of move over like an Aeroplan wing and
will not create too much excessive
motion principles of the deck which have
been developed over the course of
decades have been tested in recent years
the chagi bridge use similar principle
but it does not have the center one
because it does not carry any train the
mesina bridge this is another challenge
has been done for two but now you have
to make it three box together with this
deck Engineers say the bridge could stay
standing with winds up to 186 mph that's
as fast as the top wind speeds of a
category 5 hurricane but the high cost
isn't the only challenge to completion
critics have highlighted research that
high numbers of migrating birds could
collide with the bridge experts say that
could be devastating to endangered
species and there's even concern that
the mafia could influence construction
contracts inflating costs and adding
risk currently officials plan to break
ground in mid 2024 and finished the
bridge in the early 2030s so for now
this new world's longest suspension
bridge is still a decade
away